I want to show you this ad that I saw
literally about a half hour before we
started the show this is a Donald Trump
ad so he posted this himself on
Instagram and we've got DeSantis doing
all of the things he set out to do one
at a time just knocking down dominoes
you may not agree with all of them I
personally disagree with what he did
moving up abortion from 15 weeks to six
that's a personal disagreement I have
and that's fine but he's accomplishing
everything he set out to do donors be
damned here's what Trump put up this
morning and just see if you think
there's a little difference in tone and
Direction and the rest of it
Ron DeSantis was struggling big time in
his primary race for governor of Florida
polls revealed DeSantis was failing so
bad he was losing by a staggering 17
points then DeSantis was saved by the
endorsement of President Trump Trump's
support was so powerful just two days
after the endorsement DeSantis took a
commanding lead and it propelled him to
being elected I'd like to thank our
president for standing by me when it
wasn't necessarily the smart thing to do
you're welcome Ron unfortunately instead
of being grateful DeSantis is now
attacking the very man who saved his
career isn't it time DeSantis remembers
how he got to where he is make America
great again big league so good build the
wall then Mr Trump said you're fired I
love that part truth is there's only one
person who can make America great again
Carol I want to give the devil his due
here Trump did help DeSantis become
governor first time around he endorsed
them and helped him there's no doubt
about it I also voted for Trump last
time I'm pretty sure both of you did too
um but this thing where he has to be
grateful there's no message there
there's no reason to vote for Trump
there it's that you're scared of
DeSantis and should DeSantis just bow
forever I just don't think it works
I don't understand the whole argument
from the Trump campaign and I wrote this
in a piece a few weeks ago about this
but you know the argument that DeSantis
is this horrible globalist you know
Rhino donor show also I want full credit
for his governorship and he should just
wait four years
right and and he should wait and then
we'll support him then because then
import this globalist chill
um and look the Trump campaign is
clearly afraid of Ron DeSantis the media
is clearly afraid of Ron DeSantis I
don't blame them I don't really see
something in him that I don't see in a
lot of politicians he is a juggernaut he
is this revolutionary character where he
is making some serious changes and the
people who oppose him should be worried
because I don't see him losing on a lot
of fronts um it doesn't mean that'll
never happen doesn't mean that you know
DeSantis is going to run away with this
nomination I think Donald Trump is a
formidable opponent and it will be an
uphill climb
um but the idea that the Trump campaign
is not worried about him is just not
jiving with the reality of the way that
they're behaving and you know I don't
know if Paige is going to get into this
but the comments on that article on that
video are just all pro DeSantis here let
me let me actually show you we have a
screen capture so they disabled they
limited the comments right after putting
this up within about 10 or 15 minutes
all of the comments uh were negative and
defending DeSantis and going after Trump
and you know basically saying this isn't
working and this is nonsense and you've
gotta you know there's a case to be made
for Trump he refuses to make it so as
you can see on the bottom there I
actually I can't quite see it on the
screen it says that they're limited or
something to that effect so that's from
the Trump account uh that's from Team
Trump himself uh Pedro he's not making a
case for himself he's trying to make an
anti-case but
um yeah no that's right and by the way
the same thing happened when uh Donald
Trump Jr took a kind of very similar
line of attack against DeSantis and
posted it on Instagram oh yeah they did
the same thing